MALE SPEAKER: Our
presenter today
at Google Talks--
Annalee Newitz,
who is the founding editor
of the web site IO9.com.
I am from Venezuela.
I see it in Venezuela.
I have friends in Korea
that see it in Venezuela.
And she just published
this fantastic book
that came out last
week in paperback.
It is about scatter,
adapt, and remember.
And she's going to take us
through a travel, a visit
through the universe
and through time,
and tell us how we will survive.
So with that, I
think Annalee, we
are going to enjoy this so much.
So a big applause
to Annalee, please.
ANNALEE NEWITZ:
Thanks very much.
So I'm a science
journalist, which
means that what
I do when I write
is look at science and
culture in context.
That's usually how I
explain it to people
who wonder what that is.
And sometimes, that
context can be quite small.
Like, it might be the
context of a laboratory
where people have
made a discovery
and what it was like to do that
and how that discovery happened
and how they got funding.
And sometimes the
context is a really big.
Like, deep time, or what
happened on Earth over the past
3.5 billion years
since life evolved.
My most recent book
project, as Jose mentioned,
is about this much
larger context.
And I have to admit that
my inspiration for writing
this book was not actually
a sense of being moved
by the vastness
of space and time,
but my interest in
disaster movies,
and specifically
Godzilla movies.
So you probably all know that
I'm pretty excited right now
because there's a new
Godzilla movie coming out.
I was interested in the idea
of, as a science journalist,
what would be the real life
equivalent of a disaster movie?
Like, a horrific disaster movie.
Not one of these small scale
ones where a building burns
down or a town is
flooded, but something
where the entire planet is
being eaten by giant monsters.
What would be the real life
scientific equivalent of that?
And it turns out
to be these events
that we call mass extinctions.
And there have been
five of these events
already since life evolved on
Earth-- since multicellular
life evolved, I should say.
And that's what I'm going
to talk to you about today
is what these events are, how
life made it through them,
and what the future
of humanity is
as we face what really may
be a new mass extinction.
And we can talk about
that maybe in Q and A,
the evidence for and against
the next mass extinction.
Basically, a mass extinction
is any time when 75% or more
of all species on
the planet die out
over a period of about a
million or 2 million years.
Those numbers are huge,
but a million years
in geological time is
actually quite short.
I have a little
illustration for you
that I like of
geological time here.
And what you can see
from this drawing
is that actually, when
geologists look back
at history-- and
oftentimes, they actually
will be looking at a cliff
face where they can see layers
in the rock-- often
the boundaries
between geological periods are
marked by mass extinctions.
Because these are times when
because of that 75% number--
you have to think about that,
75% or more of all species
die out-- basically means that
an entire set of ecosystems
die and a new set rise
up to replace them.
So when you're looking
in the fossil record,
it's easy to see those
events because suddenly you
see, for example, no more
trilobytes or no more
of a particular kind of animal.
No more megafauna, giant
dinosaurs, and such.
These mass extinctions
of this magnitude,
there's only been five so far
in the history of the planet.
The more I was
researching, the more
it became clear that
there were commonalities
between these different
mass extinction events.
And I should say, there have
been plenty of other extinction
events, by the way,
where only say 30% or 40%
of all species on
the planet die out,
which is already a
huge catastrophe.
If that happened to
us now, we would all
be starving and probably
dealing with plagues.
So none of those are
fun, but the mass
extinctions, these are the ones
where you see this huge spike,
where it's just literally
almost all life expires.
And what's common
between these big events,
these big mass
extinctions, is usually
they're precipitated by
some kind of terrible event.
The most recent mass extinction
that you've probably all
heard about is the one that
destroyed most of the dinosaurs
65 million years ago
when an asteroid smashed
into the planet and there were
also mega volcanoes going off
in India.
There's some debate
over what happened next
after the asteroid
hit the planet.
But we do know is that
ultimately over time-- first,
there were explosions and fire
and things like that-- but
over time, what happened was
that that event set off climate
changes across the planet.
And that was really what
killed off most of the animals.
And we see this happening
again and again.
In all five of these previous
mass extinctions, what's
happened is some horrific
event-- maybe mega volcanoes,
I'll talk a bit about that
in a second-- maybe cosmic
radiation, but ultimately,
the long term death,
that 1 million years of
horrible everybody dying
is caused by habitat changes
and by climate changes.
So you can already see
why, for example, now,
scientists are a
little bit concerned
that we may be entering into
a new phase of mass extinction
because we are entering
a phase of extreme, what
a geologist would call
perturbations in the carbon
cycle.
Which is to say, climate
changes caused by carbon loading
in the atmosphere.
These events can be
associated, as they are today,
with extinctions.
Before I talk to you about
my favorite mass extinction,
because I have one--
everyone who studies
this stuff does-- I want to
tell you a little bit more
about those perturbations
in the carbon cycle.
I want to talk about
Snowball Earth.
How many people know
what Snowball Earth is?
OK, a few of you have studied
your ancient Earth history.
So basically, it's interesting
to think about this time
period, which happened shortly
after the evolution of life
on the planet because
it's a good example of how
life forms have been changing
the environment on the planet
since life evolved.
So humans love to think
about themselves in general,
but one of the things that we
love to think about ourselves
is it we're the
only animals that
ever came along and changed
the habitat on the planet
to the point where we are
causing climate changes.
Well it turns out that about
2 billion years ago, there
was another life form
on the planet that
was changing the environment
much more than we ever did.
And that life form was is
known as cyanobacteria.
And there is, in fact,
cyanobacteria now, too,
distant descendents of
this early life form.
It's also known as
blue green algae.
Your friend, blue green algae.
So here's what's awesome
about cyanobacteria.
At the time they evolved, which
was about 3.5 billion years
ago-- they're really early life
forms-- they had an innovation
that no other life
form had, which
was that they
could live in water
and use a photon to split a
water molecule to get energy
out of it.
And the only byproduct
of this was oxygen.
Well, the thing was, at
that time, the atmosphere
on the planet was
mostly methane-based.
So all of the archaea
and all the other life
forms living around
didn't use oxygen
in their respiration cycles.
So they're all
hanging out saying,
I love my clean,
methane-based environment.
Everything is great
because there's
no terrible pollution
from oxygen, for example.
But then these guys
come along, and they've
got this great innovation--
photosynthesis.
And they can spread anywhere,
live anywhere, anywhere there's
light and water.
And the planet is mostly
covered in water at this point.
They can live there.
And so they just
start farting out
tons of oxygen, tons and
tons and tons of oxygen,
to the point where they're
poisoning the planet.
Literally, all of the life forms
that were around at that time
either perished or
actually went to become
quite similar to the organisms
that now live in volcanic vents
at the bottom of the oceans.
Those may be distant relatives
of these early creatures
destroyed by oxygen.
No one would ever consider this
Snowball Earth event, which
I'll tell you about in a
second, to be a mass extinction
because it took a
really long time.
It was on the order of a billion
years, as opposed to a million
years.
But what happened
catastrophically
is as oxygen levels were
raised in the atmosphere,
the planet started to cool down.
This was at a time when the
sun itself was actually cooler.
It was actually that long
ago that the sun was not
sending out as much heat.
More oxygen in the
environment means cooler,
just like more carbon in the
environment means warmer.
And eventually, you started
to get these ice caps
on the planet.
And the more ice caps
you had, the more light
was reflected, which
meant the ice caps would
grow and grow and grow until
basically-- many geologists now
believe that that's kind
of what we had for a while.
The entire planet
with covered in ice.
How did this
cyanobacteria survive?
Is a big question.
People often talk
about, well, there
was maybe like a little ring
of goo around the equator
where the cyanobacteria hung out
and kept polluting everything.
Basically, the
Snowball Earth cycle
ended because of volcanism.
Lots of volcanoes
were going off,
loading the environment
with carbon,
warming things up and eventually
returning the carbon cycle
to a more even keel.
But that's how the
carbon cycle works
is it's always vacillating
between these ice
houses and these greenhouses.
We couldn't probably have a
Snowball Earth at this point
because the sun is a
bit warmer and it's
unlikely we would have such
as an intense runaway icehouse
effect.
But certainly at that time, it's
believed that possibly there
were three of these events.
So humans are not
the only ones who
pollute the environment
with our gases.
We're just the most recent and
the most famous to ourselves.
So let me tell you about the
very best mass extinction ever.
When a mass extinction
happens, as I mentioned,
it's not like
Snowball Earth where
it takes a really
long time and there's
these kind of long periods
where changes are taking place.
They're taking place quickly.
And the worst mass
extinction that ever happened
was 250 million years ago at
the end of the Permian period.
This is before
dinosaurs evolved,
so you can't imagine
giant monsters
lumbering around on the planet.
It was a period when there was
a lot of life in the oceans.
There were some animals
on land, and plants.
And the earth actually had one
super continent called Pangea.
So all the continents were
kind of pushed together.
And it was a continent that
stretched from the North Pole
down to the South Pole.
So it was a long,
not really narrow,
but it was a long kind of
vertical continent, as opposed
to earlier versions
of Pangea, which
were all at the
bottom of the planet.
That was a bad time
when that happened.
So we have this
nice big continent.
Everything's going along great.
Life has been evolving
and diversifying.
There's lots of plants.
And suddenly, or perhaps not
so suddenly, a mega volcano
starts going off in
what is now Siberia.
And it's not a big
explosive volcano.
It's the kind of volcano where
a crack opens in the earth
and lots of lava oozes out.
And along with
that lava, you get
a lot of toxic gases, a
lot of greenhouse gases.
That's going on for
about 1,000 years.
So we have a volcano that
is emitting gas and lava
into the environment for
1,000 years, roughly.
Scientists aren't sure
if it started and stopped
or if it just kept gushing.
But it released so much lava
that actually, if you do visit
Siberia today, you can go
see the area-- it's just
called the Siberian
traps, quite beautiful
now-- which is
all volcanic rock.
But at the time, it's
estimated that probably
the amount of lava would
have covered northern Europe.
So it was a huge amount.
But, as I mentioned
earlier, of course
the death toll from
this event was not
from flaming waves of death.
Because lava is actually
moving pretty slowly.
So it's not like you
couldn't do the action movie,
like, I'm running
away from the lava.
You actually could
have done that,
and animals did run
down out of the North.
But the problem was
all of the carbon
loading in the environment.
So you get a lot of the
same-- at that time, we now
see traces in the rocks of that
era of the same exact kinds
of problems that we're
dealing with today.
There was incredible
ocean acidification.
There were anoxic, dead
places in the ocean where
there was so little
oxygen that animals just
couldn't survive there.
Corals died off.
In fact, there are
beautiful coral reefs
that just were gone.
It was very, very difficult for
life to continue in the ocean.
And of course, on land, there
was almost total devastation.
In fact, it's estimated
that 95% of all species
died off during this period
after the volcano had
been erupting.
And it was because
of climate change.
It was because you had
this incredible greenhouse
situation.
One of the scientists who
I talked to about this
said, what came
after this period,
he likes to call slime world.
Because basically,
it was a great time
to be slime because there were
a lot of dead bodies to eat
and slime adapt really
well to acidic environments
in the water and
environments on land
where the situation
is sort of terrible.
One of the only remaining
survivors on land, this event,
was a four legged animal
here called Lystrosaurus.
Lystrosaurus kind
of became my mascot
while I was writing this
book, partly because it looks
a little bit like
a pig and a lizard,
which is always This animal
is called a synapsid.
They're often called
mammal-like reptiles
because they were reptiles
that over time began
to evolve more and more
mammal-like features
and eventually, the ones
that didn't go extinct
evolved into mammals.
So this is kind of our
evolutionary uncle here.
It's because of these creatures
that we're here today,
and because of their heartiness
in the face of this disaster.
There's a lot of
theories among geologists
about why they survived
because of the fact
that after this horrific
mass extinction,
they were pretty much
the only land animal.
There were animals
that were aquatic.
There were animals that
were kind of alligator-like.
These guys somehow managed to
not just survive, but speciate,
meaning they evolved into many
different species over millions
of years.
They migrated down from the
northern parts of the continent
to the southern part
of the continent,
so that when the mega continent
broke up into two continents,
there were already just
tons of Lystrosaurus
and its offspring in
the southern continent.
And they were just
incredibly adaptable.
They were burrowers,
which meant-- in fact,
we found some amazing
skeletons of them
recently inside their burrows.
They may have been adapted
to environments that already
had a lot of dirt
and gunk in the air.
That's possibly one
reason they survived.
It may have just been
that they were lucky.
There may have been no predators
that survived that ate them.
Because basically, they were
kind of the cows of the era.
They would have been a
really nice, tasty treat.
I talked to an environmental
scientist who said yeah,
they're just like cows.
They weren't very big.
They were sort of dog sized.
And I don't know how
tasty they would.
But the point is, nobody
was really eating them.
The point is, if these
creatures could survive,
it gives us a good
way of understanding
how other animals make
it through these kinds
of catastrophic events.
And that's what
brings me to humanity.
One of the things that I saw
again and again in looking
at animals that survive mass
extinctions was that they had
a lot of things in common with
Lystrosaurus, for example,
which is they could adapt
to many environments.
They could eat almost anything.
And they were able to
spread out away from danger.
One of the things that people
have as animals-- just thinking
about people as animals, and
not getting worried about things
like science and wearing
awesome dresses like the people
in this picture
are-- as animals,
we are an invasive species.
We're terrific at going into
new areas and adapting to them.
We terrific at scattering
in the face of danger
to get into better
circumstances.
And, as I am fond of pointing
out, we can eat garbage,
and it seems to be just
fine, as you've perhaps
seen in your life.
So we have the baseline
characteristics
of a species that can survive
one of these disastrous events
that lasts for these
long periods of time.
The thing that we have
that, as far as we know,
Lystrasaurus did not have,
and many other survivors
of mass extinctions
like birds did not have,
is that we have an ability
to record our history.
We have science and technology
which use the scientific method
to explore problems and come
up with solutions to them.
So we are actually
able to figure out
that we might be headed into
a mass extinction, which I'm
highly doubtful that
Lystrasaurus did.
Because we can know
that, because we actually
discovered things like carbon
cycles 50 years ago or so,
we're able to make
plans for the future.
And that was what I really
became interested in,
and that's what a large
part of my book is about
is how we can learn
from what's gone on
before on the planet from these
disasters and these extinctions
and what we can do to
plan for the future.
So the question is,
if you're looking
to the future with
survival in mind--
if you are taking the
warnings that we're
getting about climate change and
animal extinctions seriously,
what are the steps that we
can take as a civilization
to prepare ourselves to survive?
One of the first things that
I think we have to consider
is the fact that
human beings right now
are starting to live
mostly in cities.
So I wanted to look at a
near-term future scenario
for how humans might
start surviving.
And when I say
near-term, I really
mean the next 100
to 200 or 300 years,
so it's not particularly
near-term, like it's not
next year, but in the
rather near future.
More than half of humans are
already living in cities.
And over the next
100 years, it's
likely that those numbers
are really going to jump.
We may be up to something
like 75% of people living
in cities by the
end of this century.
So how do we change our cities
to be robust against disaster?
So first of all,
as I've mentioned,
one of the big problems
with mass extinction
is climate change.
So how do we start making cities
that are more sustainable?
How do we start building so
that they can survive things
like floods, which are
inevitable with climate
change, earthquakes, which
are inevitable because we're
in California, and other kinds
of disasters which might be
even more outlandish, like
rocks from space or radiation
from space?
One of the things that
we need to think about
is-- and I have this building
with biology injunction
here, because one of the ways
that these kinds of disasters
take place, these
mass extinctions,
is not particularly exciting.
Mega volcanoes actually
are kind of exciting.
Asteroids from space, pretty
good on the exciting scale.
But generally, when you start
having these climate changes,
the reason why
animals die out is
because of famine
and starvation.
It's really simple.
When you start having
habitats change,
food sources become
less and less available.
Herbivores that eat plants--
if the climate changes,
those plants are no
longer available.
If those herbivores die out, the
carnivores that eat them also
die out.
So you get this kind
of knock-on effect
where the food webs, which
are the webs of who eats whom,
start to unravel.
So if we're going to
focus on how humans
can live in the future to
survive that kind of disaster,
A, we have to focus on
places where we're living,
and B, we have to
focus on how we
can use those places to
maintain our food security
and to maintain sustainability
so that we're not trashing
the places where we're
actually building our food.
This means partly
rethinking our technology
to incorporate things like
bio mimicry and biology.
That can be as simple as
turning to alternative sources
of fuel-- solar fuels,
biofuels, anything that's
carbon neutral or
carbon negative.
But more
futuristically, we could
be starting to think
about how cities
can function like
environmental systems.
And this is something that
very few people realize
is going on in environmental
science right now,
but there's a huge
push to just gather
shit loads of data on how
environmental systems work.
To literally go into an
environment or habitat,
count how many
animals are there,
count the kinds of
things they're eating,
trying to figure out
all of the inputs that
go into an environmental
system and all
of the outputs that result.
And the inputs are
strange and surprising.
For example, there's
a team in Canada,
at University of
British Columbia, that's
been studying the
composition of the microbiome
in forests that
are being farmed.
They're just looking to see
if farming forests over time
is changing the kinds
of bacteria that
are available to the
trees in the soil.
Bacteria, of course, are
very important for trees,
because they help with
all kinds of things
like nitrogen uptake
and other processes.
So what they found is that
yes, farming in forests
actually cuts down on the
diversity of the microbes
that you have
available in the soil.
And that's, again, a very
data-intensive process.
I was talking to their
field scientists,
and they were like yep,
we just go into forests
and collect chunks
of soil and sequence
it to find out what genetic
material is in there.
So there's a huge data
gathering effort right now.
Over time, people are going
to be using programs to crunch
that data to simulate
environments to think about how
do you, for example, put
inputs into an environment
or a habitat that change
the way it behaves?
Maybe you can change the
way crops can survive
in different kinds of climates.
Maybe you can change the
way crops produce sugar
so that you can take
more energy from them.
There's all kinds
of ways that we
can intervene in environments
in a sustainable way
to also make them
fit in with how
humans are living in cities.
The other thing that we
need to be thinking about
as we head into
future is actually not
just making cities that
function like a metabolism
or that interact with
their environment
better once we understand
how environments function,
but actually building
our city environments
using biological materials.
So one of my favorite examples
of what I'm talking about
are self-healing materials.
You've probably heard of
self-healing materials.
There's a lot of
self-healing polymers
that are used right now as
ship sealants, for example.
When they're exposed to heat,
the cracks will close up.
Here, what I have is a couple
of pictures from a science
project that a group
of undergraduates
did for the IGEM
competition, which
is an annual synthetic
biology competition.
And what they created was
self-healing concrete,
which is made with bacteria.
It's modified bacteria, and they
referred to it as BacillaFilla,
which, if you're a bio geek,
is a really hilarious joke.
They were using
bacteria that basically
had been modified
to extrude epoxies
when in contact with cement.
So as you can see
here, we can see
a crack that had been
made in some cement.
This is obviously magnified.
They smeared a bunch of
bacteria on it, and over time,
that bacteria grew
to fill in the crack.
And it extruded these
epoxies, which actually
made that concrete
stronger in the end.
I should add, by
the way, that when
people do these kinds of
synthetic biology projects
where they're trying to
create biological materials,
one of the important things
is building a kill switch
into the bacteria so you're
not going to get runaway cement
tumors forming on your
head and things like that.
Although that is,
obviously, a danger,
because things can go wrong.
So it's important that
this is regulated.
What they've done
here is show us
a glimpse of what cities
might be like in a future
where we start building with
modified biological materials
that are, in fact, still alive.
So not building with
dead trees, but building
with living materials that
could in fact heal themselves.
Which is very
sustainable, and in fact,
in a city like San
Francisco, where I live,
would be fantastic
because we're constantly
in danger of quakes weakening
infrastructure because
of cracks, and things like that.
You can imagine in the future--
I talked to this architect
in New York who works a lot
with synthetic biologists who
said his vision for
a city in the future
is basically something that
looks like a ruin that would be
covered in scars that had formed
from self-healing buildings,
covered in vines that have
been modified to do things
like purify water, or covered
in vats that are bubbling up
cyanobacteria that have been
modified to produce fuels.
One of the outputs
of cyanobacteria
can be hydrogen
fuel or other fuels,
depending on how you modify it.
It would be this city that was
partly alive and partly made
of standard city
materials, but it
would look like this ruin
covered in plants, covered
in scabs, but it would be
this living, vital city that
was almost indistinguishable
from the nature around it.
So it would be kind
of like visiting
an ancient city of the
Maya-- stumbling across it
in the forest, in the
jungle, and yet, it
would be almost like
a living organism.
The idea behind that,
of course, again,
is always about trying to make
human habitation on the planet
as close as possible to the
already existing ecosystem
so that we halt this
process, this mass extinction
process that's caused
by climate changes.
The fact is that
even if we manage
to completely change the
way our cities behave,
geoengineer the planet,
fix the environment,
live in beautiful cities
that look like trees
and become elves or whatever
else we're going to do,
there's still a basic problem.
I mentioned to you earlier
that these previous mass
extinctions, one was
caused by mega volcanoes.
Another was caused by a giant
ball from space smashing
into Mexico.
And these aren't problems
that are going to go away.
We actually live on a
tectonically active planet.
Volcanoes could come
back at any point, really
big mega volcanoes.
By the way, Yellowstone
is not one of those.
You can ask me about that later.
People always ask me
about Yellowstone.
That's not as dangerous as some
of the other mega volcanoes
that we're looking at.
That would just screw things
up for a couple of years,
as opposed to a millennium.
So what do we do about that?
And the question is really
aimed at a far future look
at where humanity
would go to survive.
If we expect to
survive as a species,
we can't continue to stay here.
We have to eventually think
about taking our species
off the planet and into space
habitats or other worlds.
Because put it this way-- if
the whole planet is smashed
by an asteroid, we'd like to
have a backup civilization
somewhere else so that
humans can continue on.
So the question
is, first of all,
what is this time scale on
which this might happen?
People often think, why don't
we just go to space tomorrow?
I mean, there's a
Mars mission plan.
We're all going to go move to
Mars in like a decade, right?
I think that we have to think
about our move towards space
as being something that is
a much longer scale plan.
A very long term plan.
And I think a good
thought experiment
for that is to recall that the
first time that humans crossed
an ocean to colonize
a new continent
was about 50,000 years ago when
humans left Asia and took boats
very much like this one, these
reed boats, down to Australia,
and many thousands of years
later to the Americas, as well.
And they were able to do that.
They were able to
take their reed boats,
get to a new continent,
and inhabit it.
But it wasn't until
about 500 years ago
that boats were able
to completely transform
human culture and create global
trade and the global culture
that we think of as being
human culture today.
There was a really
big lag time between
first successful deployment of
boats for a cross-ocean voyage
and global culture created
around a whole shipping
trade and a whole
shipping system.
So I don't think it's going to
take 50,000 years this time.
I think we probably
can accelerate
the process a little bit.
But I think that it may
take longer than we think,
and that there's going to
be a lot longer that we're
going to have to spend here
on Earth analyzing things
like ecosystems and environments
and changing the way
that we live on the earth
before we can go to space, not
the least of which
because we're going
to need to invent
alternative fuels if we
want to go to space.
I hate to break it to
you, but rocket fuel?
Kind of last
century's technology.
We're going to need something
more sustainable than that.
We're going to
need something that
works a lot better than that.
And also, when we go to space,
we're going to need ecosystems.
We still eat things.
We still need bacteria in
our guts to be healthy.
So we're going to need to
bring all these environments
from Earth with us
into space, probably
in a very modified version.
Let's just talk about
space for a second.
If we're going to actually have
a sustainable space culture
equivalent to that culture I
was talking about where we had
those shipping lanes where
boats could cross the ocean all
the time and bring you awesome
crap from other countries,
we're going to need something
like a space elevator.
This is just one of many kinds
of big engineering projects
that have been suggested as
alternatives to using rockets
to get people and things out of
the gravity well of the planet.
The biggest expense in
terms of energy and money
is always, how do you get
the heck out of the gravity
well and into space?
What we need is a renewable
way of doing that.
So in the '90s, some
researchers at NASA
actually took an idea that
had been tossed around
amongst futurists
and science fiction
authors for a while
to actually talk about
how what would a space
elevator really be like?
The idea is just that you
have-- it's a bit futuristic--
but the idea is that you float
a counterweight on a tether
that's attached to
the planet-- and it's
about 60,000 miles up-- and
it's attached at the equator,
and it's basically in
geostationary orbit
around the planet.
And this tether that's
anchoring your counterweight
to the planet is the
big question mark.
We understand how a
counterweight works.
Maybe we'd capture
an asteroid to do it,
or something like that,
because this is the far future.
But what would actually be this
lightweight, amazing material
that would link the Earth
with this counterweight?
We don't know yet.
There's a lot of theories.
But the idea is
that you would have
some kind of robotic device
that would climb up that tether.
It's referred to generally as
a tether in the space elevator
community.
They have an annual
meeting every year
where they talk
about possibilities
for how you would
build this tether.
The robots, by the way,
we've got, as you know.
You can easily build a robot
that can climb up a rope.
Especially if your rope is
mostly in a zero gravity
situation, it's
very easy to pull up
an elevator car that
might be quite large.
Here you can see in this
NASA artist's conception.
You would have a pretty
darn big elevator car.
It would take you
probably three days
to get up that
tether into space.
So it's like a sleeper car.
And people are going up.
And also, again,
materials are going up.
This is a way of pulling
materials out of the gravity
well so you can start actually
constructing things in space.
Because again, that's going
to save you a lot of energy.
It's going to save
you a lot of money.
If you actually had a
working space elevator
and you had a tether
made of carbon nanotubes
or whatever we end up
building it out of,
you can be pulling people
up out of the gravity well
three times a day.
So you could actually have a
sustainable, repeatable way
of getting people and
objects into space.
And that would
really be the gateway
to a true space-going
civilization.
But we don't really know what
that would be like in the end,
going into space.
Humans, in order
to live in space,
would have to probably
be modified in some way.
We'd have to be genetically
modified in the same way we
might genetically
modify our plants to be
more sustainable, for example.
We would need to resist
radiation damage.
If we were going to go
live on another world,
we might need to
be able to breathe
in other kinds of atmospheres.
And that's a huge
leap to think about.
When I was
researching my book, I
kept interviewing synthetic
biologists and asking them,
so when are we going to
start modifying humans
so they can live in space?
Even though people are
kind of studying this,
I could not get a
single biologist
to go on record saying we
would ever modify humans, ever.
Simply no.
Which is probably a good sign.
But I would up asking the
science fiction writer
Kim Stanley Robinson, who wrote
the "Red Mars" series, which
is fantastic, if
you haven't read it.
So all of his novels
include this idea
that humans will be genetically
modifying themselves
out the wazoo all the time
in order to live in space.
And I said, well, OK,
none of these scientists
will admit they would
ever want to do this.
So how are we going to do that?
What's your idea as a
science fiction writer?
Like, how are we going to make
that leap from here, where
we will never modified
the germ line because it's
our precious, bodily germ
line, to modifying ourselves
like crazy?
And he said, it's
going to be longevity.
As soon as we have a
way to modify our genome
to live longer, that'll
open the gateway.
And people will start
to be willing to think
about other ways of
modifying their genomes
and other ways of
changing the species.
So that was his theory as
a science fiction writer.
Scientists have no theories
yet because they're not
going to do it.
So somewhere in between those
two possibilities, I think,
lies our future as a species.
I want to conclude by
saying that what we've
seen from previous
mass extinctions
and previous transformations
in the history of the planet
is that ultimately,
the one thing that's
held in common between all
these life forms that survive
is that they evolve.
And so the question
is, will humans
evolve because we intervene
in the process of evolution,
change our genomes
so that we can
be more compatible with
environments in space,
change our genomes
so that we're more
compatible with
environments on Earth?
Will we change the genomes of
many of the plants and animals
around us to make them function
better with human needs,
transforming plants
to be better biofuels,
transforming animals to
be working companions
that are more functional?
We just don't know
what will happen.
But we know that there
will be these changes.
And when we look back, of
course, to our ancestors
like Homo Erectus, it's
obvious that these changes
have taken place before.
And there's no reason to
think that won't again.
And we do have-- as
I said, as animals,
we have these basic
survivor traits.
We are going to make it through.
The question is
just, will we make it
through in a horrible state
of famine and poverty?
Or will we take measures now to
start planning for disasters,
planning for mass extinctions,
and building a better
civilization that is a
survivable civilization so
that we can live in style and
maybe one day go to space?
So that's the decision
that we have to make now.
The good news is, we'll survive.
But also the bad news is even
if we make wretched decisions,
we'll probably
also survive, too.
So there could be a very
dark survival scenario.
We have time for Q and A now,
so I'll open it up to you guys.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Any promising
exoplanets for us to move to?
ANNALEE NEWITZ: It's funny,
we don't know of any yet.
NASA and ISA are in the process
of developing instruments that
might actually allow us
to analyze atmosphere
on other planets.
Right now, we can't
really do that.
We do know that it's looking
more like super earths probably
have continents,
which is good news,
unless we want to
modify ourselves
to be aquatic animals.
Within our own solar
system, of course,
there's places like
Europa, despite what
we were told in the movie
2010-- all these worlds
are yours, except Europa.
Europa is a moon
of Jupiter that has
an ocean beneath its icy crust.
So there may be a
possibility of life
there, growing life there for
us to eat, things like that.
But then there's
always the question
of if we go to a planet and
there's already life there,
how ethical is it for us
to go and insert ourselves
into that ecosystem?
So my feeling is
probably in the end,
we'll end up living in
synthetic structures
that we build in space.
The science fiction writer
Iain Banks always said,
a planet is a terrible
use of matter.
Because you could always just
take a planet apart and turn it
into a giant halo world
and there'd be a lot more
surface area.
Again, you'd only want to
take apart a dead world.
You don't want to rack
some exo ecosystem.
That is my sense of where we
might be going, if we're lucky.
But so far, I think
we're just going
to have to stick with
our solar system.
So maybe Europa.
Next you're in Europa.
AUDIENCE: I was curious, what
are your thoughts on things
like fracking and
how it's affecting
climate change versus
what's going on
with the natural progression
of the Earth, anyway?
ANNALEE NEWITZ: I think
fracking is a last ditch effort
to suck the last fossil
fuels out of the planet.
It's kind of like when you get
to the bottom of the mayonnaise
jar, and you're like sticking
your tongue in the bottom,
like.
Probably none of you do that
because mayonnaise is gross.
But it's basically the
equivalent of that.
And I think it's testimony
to how desperate we
are for fuel and energy.
It's obviously a terrible
long-term solution.
What we really need
to be focusing on--
and luckily what even in our
government here in the U.S.
is gently trying to focus
on, especially the Department
of Energy, are alternative
fuels that are carbon neutral.
So whether that's
biofuels or-- I'm
a particular fan of
solar fuel generators.
There's a group at Berkeley
that's partnered with a group
at Caltech called the Center
for Artificial Photosynthesis.
And what they're
trying to do is build
a device that is ultimately kind
of like a photovoltaic device.
But it also uses water.
It produces a
hydrocarbon liquid fuel
that is from sunlight and water.
It's particularly
seductive to me
because you can work with the
existing fuel infrastructure
that we already have, which is
designed around liquid fuel.
One of the big problems
with solar and wind energy
is storage.
How do you store that energy?
So if you could get
liquid solar fuel,
this hydrocarbon, that
might be a really great way
to transition into
an alternative fuel
source without having to change
the infrastructure as much,
because changing the energy
infrastructure is a huge cost.
Although, of course,
building fracking facilities
is also a huge cost.
So it would really be nice
to see people investing
in alternative
infrastructures, too.
I guess the short answer is
TLDR fracking is a dead end.
Alternative fuels are
going to be the way
to survive long term.
AUDIENCE: Great
to have you here.
Thanks for coming out.
You've touched briefly on
the self-healing materials.
And I was wondering if
it's just the concepts
and the competitions.
I haven't done any
research on that,
but it's really
interesting to me.
If there are already some
materials that have been used,
and how the regulators and the
government are reacting to it.
What do you hear?
What do you read about it?
ANNALEE NEWITZ:
So yes, there are
a few self-healing materials
that are in use now.
The self-healing
polymer materials
that I was mentioning
before that
are used in sealing
ship holes, for example,
and other industrial uses, those
are biomimetic in the sense
that they're trying to
imitate a biological process,
but they're not
actually biological
like the BacillaFilla
that I mentioned to you.
I am not aware of any
product like BacillaFilla
that's on the market.
There are certainly in the
pipeline at various research
institutions.
Self-healing materials generally
are a huge focus of interest,
both for defense
and for industry
because if you can
have, for example,
a self-healing material that
when you shoot it with a bullet
closes up again-- there actually
is a transparent polymer that
can do that.
I saw a great like
a Discovery Channel
special where they showed it.
Again, not in widespread
deployment, but in the research
stage.
So it's a very big area of
investment in material science
right now, and you'll find a
lot of material science labs
that are focusing on
that particular area.
And like I said, it's
sustainable as well
being a possible way of thinking
about building materials
as a part of the
living environment
instead of as
something that's dead.
AUDIENCE: Some years ago
in Scientific American,
there was an article on one
possible mass extinction
mechanism of if we kill
off enough of aerobic life
in the upper layers
of our oceans,
there's some perfectly
happy anaerobic life
down in lower layers that could
come up and start farting us
all to death with
hydrogen sulfide.
Have you heard any more
updates to that theory?
ANNALEE NEWITZ:
Actually, there was
a paper that came out just
a few weeks ago about that.
And it was actually looking at
the Permian mass extinction,
which I was explaining to
you in such glowing terms.
And one of the
theories now is that
a methane-producing microbe was
adding to the greenhouse gas
loading in the
atmosphere at that time.
So basically, what can happen
is, as you probably know,
if you get acidification
in the oceans,
oftentimes that can lead
to all algal blooms.
And so if you get some
of these toxic bugs that
are producing things
like methane gas,
they might start thriving
in the environment
that we consider to be toxic,
which is probably like revenge
for Snowball Earth
in some broad sense.
Yeah, no one knows for sure.
But it is a theory,
and it's certainly
something that could happen.
As you probably remember,
when we have big oil spills,
for example, one
of the outcomes can
be bacteria eat a lot
of the oil and produce
these anoxic zones in the ocean.
So bacteria can be involved
in a lot of processes
that create life
for the bacteria,
but then destroy habitats
for other creatures in them.
Yes, bacteria and other
microbes are probably
deeply involved in
mass extinctions.
And of course, now we
know that the human body
is host to so many
biological organisms that
keep us healthy, too, so
changing our environment
can actually be killing
off the microbes
in our bodies that
are keeping us alive.
Basically, the
future is studying
the environment
created by microbes
and how that affects us.
Most realistic movie or fiction
about a disaster on Earth?
I would have to say-- I'll just
pick on Kim Stanley Robinson
because this is
actually something
that he writes about a lot.
He has a novel that came
out a couple years ago
called 2312, which
I think is probably
my favorite novel of his.
I highly recommend it.
It's set, not surprisingly,
in the year 2312.
It's about a future where
a lot of the geoengineering
and biological engineering
ideas I've been discussing today
have actually come to pass.
There are radical bioengineering
and environmental remediation
groups who come back
to Earth from space
and their goal is to raise
Florida out of the ocean
again because Florida has
been completely submerged,
and of course, displacing
many people and many animals.
So they are engaging
in this sort
of a blending of
environmentalism
and geoengineering and
slowly raising that.
They're also repopulating
parts of the United States
with wolves, as well, which
is really interesting.
They're actually
parachuting wolves
in from their spaceships where
they've been growing them
in their space habitats.
It's actually quite a beautiful
image, these wolves parachuting
down into their new environment.
I think the thing that
I like about that is it
is about this environmental
disaster that we're facing now,
but it imagines a future where
environmentalism is deeply
connected to geoengineering
and bioengineering,
that those two groups
are no longer at odds
and they've figured out a way
to use scientific interventions
into the environment
and into habitats
to remediate the environment.
So they're not
viewing bioengineering
as the enemy, but as a tool
to fix the problems that we
have on the planet.
That's very utopian.
I think that would be
a fantastic outcome.
I don't know how likely it is.
But it's certainly a very,
very realistic picture
of what climate
change would be like,
and then a hopeful picture
of how we would fix it.
AUDIENCE: What's your opinion
about technology singularity?
ANNALEE NEWITZ: Technology and?
AUDIENCE: Singularity.
ANNALEE NEWITZ: I think
that the future belongs
to environments and
ecosystems and biology.
And I think we're far more
likely to have a good future
if we work on treating the
planet like a computer.
Instead of trying
to turn the planet
into a substrate for our
brains to jack off forever
to zombies and plants,
which sounds really
good in some ways, maybe what
we might think about instead
is that the planet itself
is an incredibly complicated
mechanism with many
inputs and many outputs,
and that our long
term goal could
be to understand all
of those and actually
start intervening meaningfully
so that we're actually
shepherding the entire
environment of the planet
and using our technology to
maintain sustainable ecosystems
and to maintain the planet at
a temperature that we enjoy.
We like it a little cool.
We like those ice caps.
As you may know, the
ice caps are actually
kind of an unusual thing
for the planet to have.
For most of the
planet's history,
there have been no ice caps.
It's been warmer, more
carbon in the environment.
But if we can
start to figure out
how to control this amazing
machine that we live on,
maybe we can intervene
and prevent those ice caps
from going away and keep the
ecosystems that we enjoy here.
And then maybe we can
go into space, as well
and bring our ecosystems
along with us.
And I think that's a much more
hopeful view of life evolving.
I feel like evolution
and change really
need to characterize
our future, not
uploading in a kind
of static world.
AUDIENCE: Climate changing is
coming toward us very fast.
What do you think
that Google people,
as a powerhouse of
internet, have to do?
ANNALEE NEWITZ: One of
the things about Google
is that it's already
creating a sort
of small, utopian
community, despite all
of the pitfalls along the way.
I think that as a company,
Google is actually
actively trying to invest
in futuristic, sustainable
technologies in a way that
actually really surprises me
all the time.
I read the other day
that Google X now
has to add a little
pinch of science fiction
to every project, which
could be actually disastrous,
but that's a good start.
To add to that
more specifically,
I think that one of
the things that Google
has shown other
companies is that there
is a potential
for learning a lot
from massive amounts of data.
And as I hinted earlier, what
environmental science needs
right now is massive
data gathering
and massive simulations
based on that data
so that we can
start to understand
the machine that's the planet.
And so I think that
Google provides
a nice model for how
that could be done.
How you sell advertising
to environmental simulation
technology, I leave to the
future to figure that out.
AUDIENCE: So you've talked a
lot about genetic engineering
and genetic
evolution that we can
use on ourselves to
go towards the future.
But what cultural
and social evolutions
do you see as also
being, or possibly
more necessary, in
order for us to have
a more positive
outlook for our future?
ANNALEE NEWITZ: That's
a huge question.
And one of the things that I
consciously did in this book
and in my research was
focus on the science
and the technology and
the engineering questions,
because many of those are
close to being solved,
which is great news for
engineers and scientists
because yay, we've
fixed everything.
Now we just have to
get implementation.
How do we scale it
and how do we get
people to adopt these
radical ways of looking
at the environment
or the future?
I think the main things that
we need to change, really, are
how we plan for the future.
I think that's one
of the biggest issues
that humans have to deal with
is thinking in terms of not just
next year, but what's
going to happen
in a generation or
two generations.
And I think that's one
of the big problems
that people who talk
about climate change
deal with, because they're
talking in these 100 year time
spans, and ordinary
people say, well,
how can you tell from a
computer simulation what's
going to happen in 100 years?
It's very hard to
answer that question.
To us, that might be like,
well, duh, of course.
Because we've put
in all the inputs
and we have a picture
of what might happen,
a statistically likely
picture of what might happen.
There's many things
that we can do.
There's science
education to get people
thinking about this stuff.
There's ways of
getting people to think
about changing how we treat
the environment by thinking
about things like food
security and energy security
instead of saving the animals,
which I really want to save
the animals, but that's
a hard sell for people.
But if you can say, we're
saving the future of food
or we're saving the
future of energy,
that allows groups like
the Department of Energy,
which is really investing
heavily in alternative energies
right now, that helps them
frame the story in a more
pallatable way for people
across the political spectrum.
So I think it involves reframing
the questions a little bit.
That's why I like to
use the term survival,
because I think that
everyone understands
the value of surviving and
their lineage surviving.
And I think hopefully,
our ideas are
going to evolve alongside
the technologies.
And I just want to finished
with a somewhat utopian thought
here, which is
that when you start
getting frustrated about how
people aren't changing quickly
enough to fix things, consider
the fact that we didn't even
know that there was a
carbon cycle 50 years ago.
We really didn't.
We didn't realize that
what humans were doing,
our Industrial Revolution, was
equivalent to a mega volcano
going off in Siberia
for 1,000 years.
We just didn't know that.
And 50 years later,
environmental issues
and alternative
energy issues are
at the top of many
political leaders' lists
of things they at least have
to pay lip service to, if not
actually engage in terms of
policy and policy changes.
So that's a huge--
that's one generation
we went from totally
clueless to actually starting
to think about
solving the problem.
So humans actually do
solve things over time.
We also screw things
up, I realize that.
There's the whole
Middle Ages issue.
But at the same time,
I have hope that
in perhaps even a
shorter time span
than we thought may be able to
solve some of these problems.
Thanks very much.
[APPLAUSE]